do you think any guns are unnecessary
like for normal people to have or are
you just like I think everybody should
have everything everyone should should
be a right what what do you think um
yeah that's tough like you have in
certain states and stuff giving certain
licensing which apparently isn't
terribly hard to get you can get like an
old Soviet artillery gun and there's
people private owners that own tanks
with live guns in them 75 millimeter
cannons machine guns I don't think
anyone should be barred from owning
those things but I understand the
licensing required to have something
destructive that's what the ATF calls
some things there's destructive devices
quote unquote
and and these firearms I mean not even
firearms but do you have these you have
weapons that are devastating and I can
understand the logic of like yeah maybe
we shouldn't give you know like
inner-city crime gangs RPGs right right
however I think if you're if you're a
law like a law abiding owner and you can
use those things responsibly I don't
think there should be limitations on
what you can get especially because it's
a slippery slope I mean you can see it
in California right but it did but then
also like imagine if the guy who like
shoots up the Las Vegas you know right
if that guy had an RPG be insane yeah I
mean who knows I suppose I mean it would
fire a rocket right I mean he did he did
plenty of damage with the ar-15 anyway
well supposedly an ar-15 who knows I
don't know what I don't know what do you
think a lot of air 15 so what'd they say
yeah yeah so I understand the logic I
don't necessarily agree with it it's
kind of tricky it's just really tricky
yeah I don't know how I feel about it
because so in addition to the Beretta
what is the other piece of gun that I
bought you bought an ar-15 lower
receiver yeah so what I mentioned
earlier is that the only the only
[ __ ] bro Johnny little bastard
the only serialized part of that yeah
there you go that's a that's called the
stripped lower that's what I got so
that's considered a firearm it's a piece
of aluminum with holes in it okay that's
a gun that's a gun right that's
considered a gun so I had to get I had
to buy this piece in order to be able to
have
yeah and the one you the one you got
costed you about 40 bucks and then now I
can build the Rev the rest of every all
the other parts trigger internal parts
kits trigger group buffer tube the upper
receiver the barrel everything you need
on that gun you can order it online and
have it deliver to your house giving you
have a little bit of know-how and some
simple tools we'll throw it together for
you and you'll have an area 15 it's not
it's not like a we're gonna do with an
ar-15
oh shoot stuff okay yeah it's they're
[ __ ] sick man they're ar-15s are
probably the coolest rifles you can get
your hands on in my opinion in the
United States I mean they're kind of
like is it's like the the Ford f-150 of
guns you know everyone's everyone's got
one right especially in the country but
yeah yeah man they want the most popular
rifle in United States semi-automatic
shoots a very controllable easy easy to
use cartridge teens have been used
how many shoots can I do at once and
this with it depends depends on the size
of the magazine you have inside of the
gun but max swapping a magazine is not
very hard so a standard capacity
magazine throughout the countries 30
rounds less with like the military uses
on their ARS California the limits 10
rounds per magazine but I mean they make
60 round drum magazines 100-round drum
magazines for I'll probably stick with
30 or 60 right well you'll get 10 yeah
I'll do 10 yeah California um yeah cal
point is yeah you got ten yeah same
thing in your pistol your pistols
supposed to hold what 15 rounds in the
magazine California get to 10
that's the rule that's the world ten
rounds limit for whatever gun in
California I like that yeah that's thing
if you can't get it done in ten you
deserve to die I think fair enough I'm
saying though like if you a shots you
[ __ ] you know I'm saying you've killed
you you [ __ ] shot the guy's wife you
[ __ ] killed two animals and [ __ ]
blew out your [ __ ] bedroom wall nice
never ducked out every street light on
your block man yeah yeah at that point
you need to go you're really good at
that point is your turn
yeah you're the one really causing the
most trouble at that point right I just
don't like it because I don't like the
government telling me how many rounds
they think is enough right the and the
police officers I need to follow that
rule military doesn't have to I'm not
gonna go to Nevada you drive five hours
away and then
and they're 200 round belt-fed [ __ ]
machine guns over there you can have
that there
yeah I mean with a machine gun yeah
given the licensing Wow yeah but the
magazine capacity is not limited in in
most states I believe California I
believe Massachusetts New York a few
other states have magazine capacity
limits Colorado I think to see yes honey
because I believe that people I believe
that some semi-automatic weapons people
shouldn't have you know I believe that
people shouldn't be able to just rattle
off 700 rounds right but then Here I am
buying a semi-automatic weapon you buy
two you see me I'm a de Graaff weapons
ones a ones a quite capable rifle and
the other ones a very well-loved and
well used semi-automatic pistol dude nah
man they they're they're cool man
I mean once you one through once they're
all done I'm taking you out and we're
going on the range all right take you
guys to mana be a good time I doesn't
want to [ __ ] shoot somebody myself
dude come on dude you're not gonna shoot
me
well now I got a separate day than feel
oh yeah we'll go next and I know we'll
leave Co out there you'll be fine don't
worry
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one